Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! So Marvel and
Sony are down to like the last three actors
for the new Spiderman they're engaged in a
slap fight to the death to find out who's
going to be Spiderman for the next seven years
as a remember it's going to be Civil War and
then a standalone Sony trilogy supposedly
Marvel really wants Charlie Plummer Sony really
wants Tom Holland and the other person the
X factor is Matthew Lintz all very young actors
gives you an idea for what Spiderman is going
look like in these films to be like a little
kid just starting high school the idea is
is that in Civil War heavy like a freshman
in high school then in the first Sony film
he'll be a sophomore and junior and senior
in the last film see get the idea even if
it takes like seven years for them to make
all these movies the actor will still be in
his mid-20s by the time they get to the fourth
film if they want to re-up that actors contract
amongst you know many other problems that
was always a problem before actors aging out
of the role Andrew Garfield is still pretty
young but you know this is part of the big
creative reboot so of course they're going to go with a
new actor the only Marvel film that we know
Spiderman's going to be in right now Civil
War but he could appear in avengers infinity
war it's it's still a long ways off the terms
the Marvel Sony deal say that Spiderman is
part of the Marvel cinematic universe even
though Sony still owns the character so whenever
they get to like the standalone Spiderman
films they'll take the lion share the profits
but Marvel does have creative input on the
casting it in the stories that they go with
it still very much Sony Spiderman but you
know what when you see like a big board room
full of people arguing about what they want
to do with the character in the stories it
just that you know Marvel has a seat at the
table now Brian Michael Bendis told some
funny stories about being brought in to consult
on the amazing Spiderman films he made it
sound like those films were made by a corporate
board room full of people who weren't really
familiar with the comic books the good thing
now is the Kevin Fiege has a seat at that
table and it he is Mr. comic book there's
no other executive at his level that has his
familiarity with the characters so if you
don't have faith and Sony have faith in Kevin
fight you and tangentially because that you
know people like Brian Michael Bendis dance
lot like a really good Spiderman writers will
also get a lot more input that people actually
listen to Benda said that of all the input
that he gave to the Sony people about the
amazing Spiderman the Andrew Garfield version
the character the only thing that made it
into the movie were the mechanical web shooters
is like it took all of his ideas are just
going to throw men away spin and it is well
with mechanical web shooters because the actors
are considering are so young you might not
be super familiar with the stuff they've done
before my initial favorite is Charlie Plummer
I like him better in grant flats than I like
Tom Holland in Wolf Hall will falls an amazing
TV series and in both actors are great so
even if they go with one over the other I
don't think it's going to make a huge difference
in terms the quality the film I know even
less about Matthew Lintz you he's kind like
the X factor he's done a lot of TV in smaller
movies but the stuff that he has done doesn't
really give you a sense for what his Spiderman
might be like he's in that Adam Sandler movie
pixels but that's not out for a couple more
weeks so be sure and go see that you get a
good idea of what Matthew Lintz might be like
and if you guys didn't know Charlie Plummer
is an American actor Tom Holland is British
I don't really think that's going to affect
the Spiderman character that much I meet is
not can affect the quality the film is is
that when you look at Toby McGuire you know
American Spiderman Andrew Garfield British
Spiderman I I think the main differences in
their performances were their own skills as
an actor and even if you are huge fans the
actors are considering just remember they
are super young so Marvel and Sony will use
them like Play Doh, they will mold them to
get whatever performance they need out of
him is is been this ongoing Disney joke about
how they find talent like they don't find
people on the street they grow them genetically
in vats now that Marvel is part of Disney
maybe they'll start growing their own actors
in vats to all that aside though they have
to find an actor fast they started shooting
Civil War in May in the issue for about six
months of the finish in October so there almost
halfway done with the movie he gives you an
idea for how important Spiderman is to the
story meaning that Spiderman probably won't
be as critical to the story as he was in comic
books Civil War but still pretty big they
wouldn't include them in the film if he was
an important part of the story and a lot of
your asking earlier this year if you the Black
Panther was going to get that Spiderman arc
from the comics get something like that in
because Marvel owns 100% of the character
I meet yet the probably get a position him
is is much bigger and the film that his story
will be a lot more politically charged because
Wakanda has all that Vibranium. Vibranium
is like the oil of the Marvel universe like
the most precious resource every other first
world nation is going to want a piece of it
including major corporations like Stark industries
so you want to make real-world allegory Wakanda
is like Iraq Vibranium is oil so you have
like the Iraq war brewing the character Black
Panther though isn't going to be an impressionable
teenager is actually one of the richest people
on the planet in the Marvel universe seriously
Vibranium way more valuable than oil but even
he isn't going to get like the Civil War Spiderman
arc Spiderman in the comics was already friends
with the avengers so he was torn between friends
between Capt. America and Iron Man in the
movies the avengers just learned that Wakanda
was a place that they didn't even know it
existed during Age of Ultron Bruce Banner
could barely pronounce it like that's how
little they knew about it so I don't think
any of them have even met Black Panther yet
although you know Tony Stark kinda rides off
into the sunset, maybe he tried to track
him down like hmm, maybe I could do something with
all is Vibranium the big question though is
is what's going on the Spiderman the movie
your what's going on with the character the
good thing about that is the Kevin fight he
has said a few things first off he's already
web slinging around New York City he's already
got his powers and like a loaf I homemade
version of this costume but he hasn't had
any like big big a fight so he's not really
on the radar in the way that daredevil just
landed on the public radar at the end of daredevils
season one like there have been people writing
about the Devil of Hell's kitchen and that
hasn't happened for Spiderman yet to because
he's already web slinging around right now
there's not to be a spider bite origin story
to slow the movie down there might be a brief
flashback but that's probably it it's really
Civil War that's going to deal with explaining
the character so that whenever the Sony films
pick up they won't have to spend the first
20 minutes the movie doing in origin story
I think a lot of the legwork in explaining
this new Spiderman to people who have never
seen a Spiderman movie never read a comic
is going to be done between his art in Civil
War and like extra marketing material for
Marvel and Sony so they do like flashbacks
to his origin in the first Sony Spiderman
film it'll be like five or 10 minutes tops
everybody has seen that uncle Ben story so
many times onto number three Kevin Fiege
also said that this version of the character
would be the most classically wisecracking
funny Peter Parker we've seen everybody has
their favorite version from the comics but
I think the biggest Spiderman comic book writers
right now that are going to have input in
the film or the character or Brian Michael
Bendis in dan slott dance lot actually just
took over the Spiderman title again and just
to be clear that the new version the Peter
Parker that just debuted in the comics he
is not to be like that in the film he's wailed
earth there's a child he actually kills venom
like it is not to be like that is not to be
that dark think like classic Bendis ultimate
Spiderman a highschooler who talks and acts
like an actual highschooler like is that these
next four Spiderman appearances are are probably
can be like freshman year in Civil War than
the standalone films of the B sophomore junior
senior year if you're looking for a really
good wisecracking Spiderman write you something
that'll be close to what you'll see in the
movie I would just read that original Bendis
ultimate Spiderman just go all the way back
to the beginning of that that actually rides
me I don't think I've done like a like a top
five Spiderman stories video so I'll probably
try and do that in the next couple weeks deafly
before, can't so be sure to subscribe to get
that if there are any of the like Spiderman
specific videos you guys want just let me
know Marvel isn't going to comic con I know
that's like a a big thing but there will be
a lot of Marvel comics stuff there just to
be clear to I think is little confusion about
this Marvel is a going to comic on it has
absolutely nothing to do with what DC is doing
is just that they don't need to promote Antman
and Capt. America Civil War is too far away
so the not to waste money on a haulage panel
is the a lot of people on twitter saying that
Marvel isn't going because there freighted
DC in that's absolutely ridiculous that actually
reminds me congratulations to my Marvel giveaway
winner this week Mark Spector you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private message
me on the about page of my channel so get
your contact info and because I didn't have
time to make a second DC video this week of
this all announce the winner my DC giveaway
to congratulations to the squawk you also
win a Amazon gift card same deal just private
message me on the about page of my channel if
you have absolutely no idea what I'm talking
about I'm doing of Marvel and DC giveaway
every single week this summer all you have to do to enter
those is be a subscriber to leave a comment
when I post Marvel and DC video is super
simple it works just like my weekly game of
thrones giveaways which will also continue
all summer so lots of fun stuff giving away
tons of stuff the summer real big reminder
though game of thrones finales this weekend
be sure to watch it ship is going down will
be doing a couple extra videos for it why
you way for that you can click here to learn
all about the rest of the cast and Capt. America
Civil War and you can click here to start
getting ready for the game of thrones finale
thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!